today we have the great privilege of
being joined by the incomparable and
iconoclastic Blair White to discuss what
the left gets wrong on transgenderism
the problems with LGBT activism and
which pronouns we should all be using
then Arielle Davidson and amber Athey
joined the panel of deplorable x' to
talk M&Ms terrible rap performance but I
repeat myself fat kids and how the Boy
Scouts have officially become the Girl
Scouts
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show Blair thank you for
coming today we have you in studio which
is excellent now this is a total
coincidence but it's probably just
providential today we booked you just
for today we didn't realize it it is
international
you know it's National Coming Out Day
and International Day of the girl that
is it that is a tremendous coincidence
well it's a good thing you brought the
girl that we brought the girl we have
the girl in studio now for those of you
who don't know Blair I would be
surprised if anybody doesn't know Blair
at this point but check out this video
it's my view however that while the
truth can be harsh
it can't be bigoted and I don't know
maybe it's just me but I've never had a
problem swallowing the truth and I
actually think there's a power in
recognizing the truth because it'll set
you free and such transgenderism is a
mental disorder so aside from that there
is a tiny portion of the population that
are transsexuals such as yours truly I'm
a biological male who was born that way
and will die that way however as my luck
would only have it mother nature kind of
to me and gave me the inclinations of a
female there's been a number of studies
that have shown that male to female
transsexual have similar brain
structures and activity to that of
biological women because of that I
decided to take it upon myself to seek
off the help of medicine to transition
or physically resemble the body of a
woman to the best of my ability so in
any sense other than legally I guess
this doesn't mean that I changed my sex
this doesn't mean that I am an invented
new sex it simply means that I
personally found it necessary to live as
and resemble the opposite sex in the
pursuit of my own happiness you just I
don't know if you could hear that I
you just made the computers of every
lefty who watches this show explode they
just exploded their houses are on fire
I'm actually only kidding because no
lefties watch my show you are you are
like a voice of reason on this whole
issue you yourself or transgender
you but you're not insisting that
there's a third gender or a fifth gender
or at two hundred and fiftieth gender
you're not suggesting that you've become
metaphysically a woman but you know you
do resemble a woman obviously you don't
look like a man therefore it follows
naturally that you would be shunned by
the online transgender community
absolutely you know I try to take at
least in my eye it's a realistic
approach to describing transgenderism
the experience of being trans etc and
all the trans activists of course hate
me LGBT activist in general I often call
myself like the black sheep of the trans
community why do they actually saw in
Twitter someone said there are like
seven kinds of trans people you were
your own category yeah there are like
right wing left wing what why do they
resist you why do they why are they so
offended when you say things that are
obviously true that are common sense you
know I just think there's a particular
narrative that is acceptable at this
point in time and anything else you know
diverging from that is just hate it hate
facts as they call them yeah absolutely
you know the whole topic of you know
trans being a mental disorder that's
literally just a fact
it's just a venitian yeah it is if you
want to be more precise gender dysphoria
is but transgenderism is the state of
having gender dysphoria so for me it's
kind of like I don't know why that's
such a an inflammatory statement because
people have all kinds of disorders
people have anxiety depression you know
OCD OCD autism everything so I've never
understood why it's so I'm terrible to
say that or admit that but and just say
that I'm I'm a man I was born a man I've
the body of a man but there's something
in my psyche that makes me think that
I'm a woman makes me identify more as a
woman makes me want to be a woman
what is so hateful about acknowledging
that reality nothing and think about it
is that um we
you lay it out that way it actually
helps people who maybe would not
understand trans people understand the
whole problem with trans activists in
the trans community is they don't bridge
the gap between the right and the left
they stay on the left and they only
adhere to those talking points Caitlyn
Jenner Caitlyn Jenner is the one who
voted Trump right yeah but but still
probably not the best spokesperson yeah
so still not doing it the way we've done
but um the thing about it is when it
comes to this whole topic everyone just
talks past each other and no one gets
anything done so I prefer to leave the
emotional arguments out of it when it
comes to trans stuff because it makes
more sense people on the right and those
are you know my people as well yeah I
mean and would you call yourself on the
right or yeah for sure for sure and
that's why I feel like I'm bit more
understanding of the rights difficulties
understanding trans people and that's
why I really other than me you mentioned
Caitlyn Jenner there really and no other
people doing shows like this and doing
right-wing shows and really bridging
that gap and able to communicate to
those people so it was your family
right-wing I mean did you come from a
Republican family or were they or you
the are you the political black sheep of
the family
um it was half-and-half my mom's side
was the liberal side my dad's side was
the conservative side so that made for
an interesting dichotomy as far as
growing up trans as well hmm I kind of
always been like in the middle of
everything right you know being transit
and then hopping like conservative
family and then being conservative
myself but you know it's it's been
complicated did the conservative family
were they resistant to your new identity
or did they kind of go along with it uh
resistant for sure I mean it wasn't
anything ugly it wasn't anything like
throwing you out of the house no I was
never abused or anything but
and my dad was fine but it was difficult
it's getting better now though which is
great now that I'm an adult and I'm you
know I take care of myself now and doing
my thing and they appreciate me going on
shows like that like most famous person
on YouTube you know clearly been
successful in this commentary this
brings up the the right-wing resistance
to transgenderism
moving of transgenderism to a lot of the
activism that comes out of it I think a
lot of it is about the pronouns and I
struggle with this myself I don't know
which to use because my reason tells me
just as you said you know you you're
born a man you'll die a man but you now
more resemble you were certainly
resemble a woman you don't look like a
man so my reason tells me it would be
[Music]
objecting to reality to say she and yet
you're my guest you're my friend you're
my politeness would object to calling
you he you and you you and and obviously
in terms of secondary sex trait it's you
you certainly look much more like a
woman how do we resolve this this issue
between manners and politeness and civil
society and the biological facts of sex
will you certainly don't legislate it I
think that's a huge problem I was just
reading the other day and 2018 there's
about to be like harsher penalties for
misgendering someone in the health field
than for spreading HIV which is insane
that's right I saw that there making it
will no longer be a felony to
intentionally excuse me to intentionally
spread HIV
California the master generally trees
yeah just a mess but again you don't
legislate it because that turns people
off in it it also creates trans people
makes trans people a liability when they
become employees you know no company
wants to hire someone who is potentially
a lawsuit you know what I mean so that's
a problem and that's another thing it's
like a double sided swore because
they're trans activists claim to fight
for it trans unemployment and then they
do things like that um but again it with
pronouns it's like it just do what makes
sense you know what I mean like for
instance if you and I were to go to
dinner or something and I got there
before you used Oz at the table and you
told people at the front like I'm
meeting my friend you wouldn't say he's
in the black top yeah that's right
because they were using Sookie dresser
for someone else right so it's just
about what makes sense um unfortunately
there are a lot of people who seem
hell-bent on having things not make
sense you know what I mean people who
want to be referred to you with you know
third pronouns fourth pronouns is a
singular day is the worst one that that
is unforgivable it is such an offense to
grammar I can't imagine it and it's
frustrating for me when I'm in those
situations I just don't hang out people
like that if I'm around them I'm not
going to be intentionally rude or
anything but I would prefer not to hang
out with someone who has like that high
expectations for a normal conversation
with them it's kind of annoying but
other than that just do what make sense
is there a worry that the pronouns kind
of give up the the premises so in the
pronouns in any polite society you would
just say she and her to refer to you you
you identify as a woman you look like a
woman just go with it but is there
something to worry about that in that
premise by granting the premise that one
can change biological sex from male to
female from him to her that we're giving
the left a a premise from which many of
their arguments will flow even if it's
not a correct premise does that make
sense I didn't say that articulate makes
absolute sense
um I guess in a sense but at the same
time it's still about what makes sense I
mean I don't even think it's giving the
left that I think they already have that
they're gonna take it yeah
you against it when the reality is like
I don't think since I was a teenager
I've ever been called heat like even
like pre-transition when I was starting
to grow my hair out didn't know her
loans no surgery I still never got
called Pete see what I mean so it's it's
just about common sense obviously when
it comes to some people there's this one
trans activist I believe her name is
Danielle Moscato
I think it's Daniel Moscato and she's
made like no I'm saying she cuz I'm
polite but she's made no attempt to do
anything like literally male clothes
bald head no makeup no anything no in
every way no legal gender and every way
it looks manlier than you like well I'll
take it you know unfortunately there are
a lot of guys who look manlier than me
and so when it comes people like that is
very frustrating
um because they'll make a huge deal
about it but most trans people we have
to remember like the Internet is like
not real life so if you get in mind yeah
a lot of these occupants like yeah
there's crazy nuts on the internet but
most trans people orders this doesn't
doesn't doesn't matter of course and and
also there weren't that many transgender
people you know the the statistic for a
long time was he was point 2 percent of
the population or even less now that
some surveys say that number is point
six percent of the population I think
obviously there are differing numbers
because it's such a small population
uh-huh
and yet it's all anyone's talking about
and I do think that the left has made us
so reactionary on this you know I
thought they do this on everything
they've but they've incredibly made
crossdressers not fun I don't know how
they did that cross dressers have always
been fun throughout all of history it
makes it like somber think makes the the
Village in New York like this very
serious social you know come on man
they've done it on college campuses
they've made sex boring I don't know how
they did that yeah I've always said like
yeah they've always said you know
transgenderism is and should exist
outside of the normal politics because
it's not political it's biological it's
neurological
it's a conditioned psychological yeah
and when you start politicizing things
like that I mean it would suck just as
much if they started politicizing
I don't know autistic people are
something right right you know making a
group of people who are going through
enough like the political football is
really frustrating and it was a left
fault because they made it you know
their issue I often say I almost missed
the day as one like no one really knew
what it meant like everyone has kind of
always known there are some like males
who you know live as females you know
but no one's ever gotten to the Nitty
Gritty of it and now everyone's debating
these small like
insignificant facets of what it is to be
trans people yeah and they're making but
it is right now it is dominating the
national conversation all we're talking
about is bathrooms you know actually
fortunately since President Trump was
elected we're talking about like jobs in
North Korea again but before that
there's just only bathrooms that's the
Nash why is that what about 2017 our
culture left or right is makes this
relatively minor issue dominate the
national discourse right I mean first of
all I always say I don't like to be
expected to use to spend my knowledge of
how the real world works to have these
conversations because I've never had a
problem using any public bathroom I've
been in the Midwest I've been in
Michigan I've been in California where
it's super liberal and it's like I just
I've been in Texas I don't have an issue
what most people I know don't have an
issue so it's frustrating to see that
become such a huge thing when already
like you said it's such a small amount
of people and it's even smaller the
people in that group who actually have
an issue yeah I mean it's just a symbol
for the left though isn't it's just a
way to to poke the culture I think yeah
but I do think a lot of conservatives
fall into the trap of like ending up
caring about it what I mean of course I
think that's such a huge trap they fall
into I would prefer to see the
conservative movement in the future
focus on reclaiming like more of a
position and culture as far as arts and
stuff like that because the Left
dominates all of that and it's really
frustrating you know what I mean and
they think you know that I think the
right things that they're gonna win this
battle on pronoun legislation which is
coming by the way it's it's in other
countries it's coming yeah so that they
are gonna do that and obviously we have
to fight back against that and I hope
the right ones I hope the right wins on
that I mean they're going to they're
going to focus on this bathroom
legislation but really that's not where
that politics is down stream of culture
right
conservatives are such Philistines that
we don't realize that orange is the new
black or something or transparent has a
much greater effect on the culture then
apps then our little legislation or our
political candidates absolutely and I'm
also say this one thing I've learned
from doing a lot of conservative shows
and talking to a lot of conservative
hosts you're not included in this but
almost all of them have told me that
they have they don't have nearly as much
of an issue with the trans saying as
their audience
pressures them to act out and the sense
that it's almost like it's just become a
talking point and it's become you know
being Pro trans or anti trans it's just
a talking point at this point and people
are forgetting you know that it's not
that huge of an issue so that's that's
interesting because we you know I don't
ever get questions about it in the
mailbag I think it is I think it's
literally the pronouns I think that's I
think that's what they care they don't
want someone to tell them that I am
gonna dictate to you how you can view
reality I think it's there I don't think
the issue among our audience I don't
think it's about transgender at all I
think it's about lefties bullying them
into submission basically I have that's
true of other audiences but I think it's
that is common on the right I think it's
Jan if the left would let it up they'd
say like alright man for the for the 18
people who have this affliction you know
yeah it's just trying to do what you're
gonna do yeah becomes actually
unnecessary war but then it gets to the
point where it is necessary ya know so
getting to you we've talked about
politics gazillion excellent videos on
your channel that people can learn about
this but getting to you you haven't had
an easy life you've had personal
difficulties you I wouldn't share this
if it were in public but you made a
video that you were raped and as a
teenager
obviously transitioning and this gender
dysphoria has to be psychologically
stressful and to add on top of that all
of these lefties hurled insults at you
all the time on the Internet
yeah what what keeps you going what
keeps you motivated is it the religious
conviction is it a sense of mission
political mission I guess just the fact
that despite everything I really
lifelike I really love what I'm doing I
made my transition happen for myself no
one paid for it but myself
I've always up to this point pretty much
gotten everything I wanted because I
worked for it and I've made it happen
for myself I'm just like in a really
good place in life and I really love
doing YouTube I I guess a lot of the
emails I get from people saying that you
know I'm saying things they could never
say and you know all of that kind of
stuff really he was been going as well
and you know I have a good family I have
good friends an amazing boyfriend life
is good you know people everyone goes
through stuff it's just about choosing
to overcome it or live in that you know
do you think it's that though I mean you
have every reason to have a victim
mentality you've got this difficult
issue by nature of your birth then
you've had these other issues come on
but you don't haven't chosen to be there
no I think that's why not you can cash
that in a lot of cash in the sculpture
um I just think that's not a healthy way
to live I think you know being soft
starving is good but when he gets when
you're doing good things when you're
being self-serving in the sense of just
feeling pity for yourself and expecting
things to be handed to you because
something may have happened to you in
the past I mean it's really gross and
unhealthy that's not a way I want to
live I prefer to you know work hard try
for my goals be happy being loved all
that stuff I much prefer that does this
does this come from any kind of
religious point of view is that is it at
some traditional point of view or did
you just stumble on these very profound
guides to life on your own just comes
from no it just comes that you know
system being spun by Blair white yeah
I've never been religious but I think
actually now that you said it it does
come from my dad sorry their family um
hard work and never feeling sorry for
yourself and just getting what you want
was always something and sold in me from
that side of the family I think it just
stuck with me
it's just how I was raised I guess
that good old American Civic religion
right absolutely right right hard work
and not pitying yourself and just going
out there and getting really famous and
making a bunch of money that's the
American dream NJ and now all right I
could talk to you all day but we have
this excellent panel of deplorable z--
that we have to bring on and ELISA see
that I know I know you want to listen to
the panel of deplorable blares gonna
stick around for the panel we have to
talk about all of the important
political issues like mm stupid rap and
fat kids and the boy now Girl Scouts but
you don't get any of that unless you go
to daily wire.com and subscribe we want
to thank everybody who has already
subscribed you help us keep the lights
on you let me polish my Rachel Maddow
glasses it's a really good life here but
for those of you who haven't you got to
go over there right now it's $10 a month
$100 a year you get me at the end
reclaim and show you get the Ben Shapiro
show yada yada yada
I know but wait there's more the leftist
here's tumblr this every time I go out
in public I carry on my phone a little
Blair white video a little commentary
video I take the lid off my tumblr and I
just collect them and they pour down
like I'm in the center of the Amazon
rainforest so make sure this is the
perfect vessel the only vessel to
contain your leftist tears they're
delicious have them hot have them cold
always salty very satisfying daily wire
calm right now we will be right back
panel thank you for being here we have
Ariel Davidson from the Hoover
Institution we have amber Athey from the
Daily Caller ladies welcome and happy
International Day of the girl what a
privilege to have you here we have to
talk about this very important news
today the rapper Eminem belched some
gibberish about Donald Trump last night
at the bee et Awards let's hear it
wait gonna start this huh I forgot
oh yeah that's an awfully hot coffee pot
should I drop it on Donald Trump
probably not but that's all I got till I
come up with a solid got a plan and now
I got a hatchet like a my patchy would
have tomahawk I'm a walk inside a mosque
on Ramadan and say a prayer that every
time talks she gets a mop
ah I'm a stop but we better give Obama
props cuz what we got an office now's a
kamikaze that'll probably cause a
nuclear holocaust we have come a long
way from Bach haven't we
Arielle everybody tells me that Eminem
is a great lyricist but that sure does
not sound like Wordsworth to me what am
I missing so I actually got myself into
some trouble today because I started
comparing Eminem and saying 2pac was a
much better lyricist which I stand by I
think there are some elements within our
discussion of and then we have to be
able to separate sort of his past
history as being a great lyricist to his
current piece of crap that he produced
excuse my French um so I think that you
know he is a talented rapper given his
you know the style of art he usually
partes in this is a pretty abysmal piece
of work and I'll leave it at that I
think I come for economically you know
really pay homage the fact that the Iran
deal which is Obama's crowning
achievement in terms of foreign policy
actually
the risk of creating a nuclear crisis
but I will step away and let the other
ladies speak on that too we see you're
not I'm sorry you're not going to grant
professor mm his premises I do have to
disagree with you on both mmm Tupac
because my favorite rapper is puff
doggie dog and snoop snoop diddly
dudette so I guess we can compare taste
is subjective you know who can really
tell which is best after all amber
is this just a desperate attempt of a
has-been to stay relevant or does Eminem
have something to offer our culture in
2017 gosh who knows maybe a bit of both
but like Ariel said this is the most
pathetic attempt at rapping I think I've
ever seen and actually pretty
disappointing as someone who used to
listen to Eminem I used to be into rap
in like middle school in high school
because I thought I was cool or whatever
working he has thank you I appreciate
that a lot of people would disagree with
you he had some pretty disgusting lyrics
in his time you know he talked about
throwing women and in the trunk of the
car and driving him off bridges and
raping women and stuffing them in the
closet so for him to the best you can
come up with his throwing hot coffee on
Donald Trump it's a little disappointing
I think he can do a lot better yeah
where is his vicious thuggery it really
was lacking from that last night Blair
that is an excellent point that she
brings up why does the media give this
guy a pass he said horrible things about
gays about women and yet I noticed that
none of that was present in their
coverage of this today right they're so
picky choosy with you know their little
pets are what's really interesting I was
watching the view this morning and Joy
Behar it was first of all her voice is
grating but second of all she was
talking about how he's so brave
for speaking out against the president
it's like in what world every artist
every celebrity right now is speaking
out against the resume it's like roaches
it's gross and the thing about it like
the Freestyle was trash for sure my
boyfriend told me this morning
apparently he had two albums recently
didn't know that I guess didn't do all
so and then he also I
I think when George Bush was in office
he like I said he wanted him dead or
something it's just as courageous as
Michael Moore yeah I haven't I haven't
bought the latest mmcd either I think I
loved the 90s they were great in 2000
but just leave them in the past man
let's move on to the future speak
speaking of the future we there is a new
study yet a new study that shows the
greatest health crisis afflicting our
troubled planet and that is fat kids
obesity rates among children and
teenagers have plateaued apparently in
the UK at 10 percent 20 percent in the
United States the u.s. currently pays
325 billion dollars per year to treat
all of the negative health effects that
come as a result of that now in Asia
North Africa in the Middle East child
obesity rates are skyrocketing Blair the
world is so prosperous that for the
first time in history the health problem
is that our children are too fat they're
too well fed once we finally perfect the
sex robots will our culture just wither
away from too much luxury probably
that's so heartbreaking even here I went
to school for nutrition for a while so
that kind of like hits home it's really
sad you know I consider it child abuse
honestly to have an OB style of playing
at that young of an age that's Charlie
is for sure and amber does this finally
put an end all these stupid fads this
blair mentions there there's a little
bit of child abuse perhaps going on but
we always hear about how terrible GMOs
are and trans fat and gluten and yada
yada yada and they're supposed to kill
us and yet we're like the best fed
people ever and we live to be a hundred
is will this finally put an end all the
nonsense and the kale and the avocados
and all of that no probably not because
unfortunately food is politicized to to
the point where the left sort of tastes
like the GMO and environmental organic
issues and tries to make it a political
talking point and then another part of
this that I think is political is this
talk about like plus-sized models and
healthy at any size and you can't fat
shame people and to me as someone who
used to be overweight I think that's so
disappointing because like no you
shouldn't bully someone for being
overweight but I think it's good for
people
to know that that's it's not okay it's
not healthy for you to be 300 pounds at
the age of 12 and maybe you should do
something about it to change it and
really the only person that can that can
change that is yourself you can't expect
society to just accept that as as
healthier or okay Blair I know you're a
really strong advocate of the anti fat
shaming movement isn't that right no it
is interesting how a lot of this is done
in the name of supporting women but
supporting this message of healthy to
any size etc is actually it hurts women
you know women don't want to be fat
women want to be beautiful that's part
of you know the nature of women is to be
attractive be desired that's scientific
I was trying to be attractive and
desired to man brash to less success
c'est la vie I'm sorry I cut you off
right so it's like I said in the name of
women but it's lying to women as well
which is frustrating Arielle Andrew
Clavin has pointed this out before that
you know they say we live in decadent
times our colleges dawn to decadence you
know but decadence is very good for the
elites and we're all elites today aren't
we in the United States in the developed
world is is this a sign of our decadence
I mean the fact that the we don't have
to worry really as much about starvation
as we do about overeating
where does a culture go from here when
it's so luxurious and so well fed in so
many ways you know I think it's a sign
of decadence I also think it's showing
sort of the primacy the technology has
started to place in our lives um you
know you don't really need to get up to
in order to get things physically we can
just order things on Amazon now you
don't need to you know there's no
impetus to step outside and play with
your friends now you can just play video
games or enter a virtual world this is
the next step that Facebook is taking so
pretty much - in order to get anything
you like you have to you don't really
have to do much to get it so it's sort
of like you can just sit on your couch
engage and you pretty much get what you
want it's a very strange phenomenon but
I think technology has a lot to do with
it that's absolutely right and there are
few things I like more than sitting on
my couch and getting anything
there is breaking news that came out an
hour ago that the Boy Scouts will now
fully admit girls to be the Boy Scouts
and the girls can go as high up in the
ranks as they want to they can become
Eagle Scouts and we're by the way we're
not talking about transgender people
we're not doing about a girl who
identifies as a boy and then joins the
Boy Scouts just full-on girls can become
Boy Scouts
now Blair on these issues of gender you
have a unique perspective that's so
funny I thought you were talking about
you know trans cont or something it's
just girls it's just work it's just the
boy skate I think it's a money grab you
know men are all about the money and I
think they're just trying to take away
all the Girl Scouts now - does this make
any sense I mean in a certain sense by
our culture's logic it does in that the
left has always told us gender is a
social construct it doesn't really
matter of course simultaneously they
tell us it's the most important thing in
the world does it make any sense for the
Boy Scouts to now be taking away all of
the Girl Scouts I mean I guess it's not
like the hugest injustice in the world
but at the same time I mean maybe it
sounds funny coming from someone who's
trans but I do believe in traditional
gender roles I think it's really healthy
for a society so the idea that were not
teaching boys three boys anymore not
teaching girls to be girls I mean
obviously listen I'm trans but I think
you can let your transmit you're not
saying that the categories of gender are
meaningless quite the opposite you can
support traditional gender roles and
traditional gender well you know
acknowledging that there's some people
that fall outside of that made you think
that they should just keep it separate
you know what I mean like I think that's
good for a little boys to be running the
little boys etc Ariel are you gonna send
your daughter into the Boy Scouts make
it make a good Eagle Scout ever well I
think what was interesting about their
announcement was that they were saying
oh you know we want to do this because
there are some girls that want to be
part of the Boy Scout mission and I said
to myself what is this why we have Girl
Scouts
yeah um Beckett Adams actually had a
great tweet today on Twitter where he
said eventually they're just going to
you you know the Boy Scouts are gonna be
flooded with girls so then the the boys
are gonna leave the Boy Scouts and head
to the girls to join the Girl Scouts
yeah switching of roles and then we'll
rename them again to the Girl Scout the
Boy Scouts so I you know there's
something cooks really important about
how we you know I I went to single sex
education for nine years from
kindergarten to eighth grade I found it
to be hugely beneficial to have sort of
an environment that was girls only but a
way for you to you know relate to other
women without sort of the social
pressures that boys might present in the
picture so I think there's something
really valuable having the saint's
preserving the sanctity of girls only
Girl Scouts and boys only Boy Scouts but
that's just my personal opinion there's
been lots of research done that shows
that boys brains develop very
differently than girls brains and you
know when you tailor an experience to
match that developmental path it could
be hugely beneficial
I don't know necessarily how they'll be
able to carry this out if there's some
sort of mixing but you know that's
totally up to them I think it's pretty I
think it's utterly ridiculous
I think we'll see some pushback from
some parents but only time will tell
you know Ariel having gone to school
from all of those years that you were in
single sex education having gone to a
school where boys and girls commingle
and go to school together
I too will be sending my daughter to a
single sex education school I gets a
great idea you know different ways that
develops and keep them away from those
awful awful boys amber the Girl Scouts
are not happy about this they sent out a
statement last time the boys gets moved
in this direction basically saying keep
your hands off our scouts we we do not
want our organization to dissolve will
the this kind of gender discourse that's
happening right now
will this lead to the end of all female
institutions such as all female sports
all female educational institutions if
single sex schools have to admit boys
now then with her single single sex
schools yeah I don't know yeah for
example sports if I say a terrible idea
because as much as liberals would have
you believe boys and girls are
biologically different and it's really
dangerous actually to have them playing
sports together in terms of just
specifically the Boy Scouts and the Girl
Scouts I actually tweeted about this
earlier today I was in Girl Scouts for
three years and I sympathize with them
being worried that the Boy Scouts are
going to steal their scouts away because
Girl Scouts is absolutely terrible I
actually ended up quitting because I was
so bored
because I was kind of a tomboy when I
was when I was young so I wanted to go
and make fires and like shoot guns and
shoot all I wanted to do is eat cookies
we could have traded places I know right
so I always always really jealous of the
Boy Scouts because they got to go off
and go camping and don't let school
stuff and Girl Scouts at least with my
troop leader didn't get to do that but
the answer to that isn't to take away
the boys only in girls only space is
that like Ariel said I think are super
important to development the answer is
to just make Girl Scouts better make the
Girl Scouts better I know I agree we
need more cookie flavors absolutely I
couldn't agree more amber okay that is
all of our time today panel thank you
for being here especially Blair white
thank you for being so nice debut in
studio and just a little bit of
housekeeping here Tuesday October 17th
at 5 p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific there
will be the conversation with Andrew
Klavan
it will be streamed live to the daily
wire Facebook page and YouTube channel
it will be available for everyone to
watch but only subscribers get to ask
the questions so join the conversation
go over there you can ask the supreme
leader of the multiverse anything you
want to know also speaking of that
supreme leader I'll be doing a new
podcast with Andrew Clavin it's his new
story it's his new novel called another
Kingdom I will be performing the whole
thing obviously I'm never gonna work in
Hollywood again so this is one of my
last available acting opportunities it's
launching this Friday October 13th look
out for it on our you know Twitter and
Michael J Knowles and Andrew Clavin and
Facebook will be posting links to it
get your mailbags questions in because
we will be joined tomorrow by dr. Jordan
B Peterson and I will be answering all
of your most pressing questions
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show come back tomorrow we'll do it
all again
[Music]
you
[Music]